hey I'm Rachel and these are my favorite
meatless tacos everybody loves tacos and
whenever I have people come over
especially if they eat meat I always
bust these tacos out they're just a
foolproof way to introduce people to
some really delicious vegan options
my favorite taco to make is the Chipotle
chickpea tacos because they're so easy
to whip up in like 10 to 15 minutes and
in my opinion the ingredient you cannot
skip is the soy sauce because it really
gives it this delicious
umami flavor which I find you can't
really replicate with salt another
favorite is the jackfruit tacos and even
though they take a little bit longer to
make they are so so good and it's
ridiculous how much they look and taste
like pulled pork I knew I had to create
my own version because I was going to a
lot of vegan restaurants in LA and
everyone had their own version of a
jackfruit taco so I was like the world
needs this the internet needs lists and
every time I make them people are like
this isn't me this tastes like this is
pulled pork so if you have the extra
time I would definitely definitely give
them a try
[Music]
for the mushroom tacos I really love the
meatiness the meaty texture in mushrooms
so I decided to just kind of like
replicate the texture of ground beef and
by doing that I just ground the
mushrooms up in a food processor and put
them in a skillet add some soy sauce add
some some cumin some spices that are
gonna give you that like taco flavor and
yeah you really can't like the texture
is very similar to me and it's also one
of my favorites because it's really fast
and easy to make they're all my
favorites they're all like my children
everyone loves mushrooms and the texture
of mushrooms is just so similar to me
that I think it's an awesome way to
replicate that ground beef texture the
next one is the Buffalo cauliflower taco
my coworker Pierce actually had
developed that recipe and when I was
making these tacos and trying to think
of different delicious things to put in
them I was like oh my gosh Buffalo
cauliflower in a taco would be
incredible you really can't go wrong
with any of these tacos as I was making
them I was like oh the Buffalo
cauliflower is my favorite know the
mushroom wants my favorite like they're
also so good
[Music]
the breading the crisps penis also takes
a little bit of time but it's so so
worth it highly recommend so the tempeh
tacos was I remember when I pitched the
idea to my boss and she was like what
the hell is tempeh like tempeh is
something that people don't know about
but they made in their lives so a tempeh
is a fermented soybean and it's a lot
like tofu but it has more of like a more
dense almost like nutty flavor but when
you pulse it up in a food processor and
you season the heck out of it it tastes
amazing it's another thing that
replicates ground beef and I think
everyone needs tempeh in their life not
only because it has probiotics and it
has tons of protein and tons of fiber
but because it tastes absolutely
delicious and if you don't like tofu I
think you should give this a shot
because it's a lot more like dense you
really can't go wrong with making any of
these tacos they're all amazing and I
think you just have a ton of people over
and have a giant taco party and go
bananas